well let me just explore different
beautiful ideas large or small in
Quantum Computing that might jump out at
you from memory so when you co-authored
a paper titled ASM totically Limitless
Quantum energy teleportation via qit
probes so just uh out of curiosity uh
can you explain what a qit is is a cubit
yeah it's a it's a dstate uh cuit
multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
right so it's like uh well you know can
you have a notion of like an an integer
floating point that is quantum
mechanical that's something I've had to
think about um I think that research was
a precursor to later work on Quantum
analog digital conversion ah there there
was interesting because during my
masters I was trying to understand the
energy and entanglement of the vacuum
right of emptiness emptiness has energy
which is very weird to say and our
equations of
cosmology don't match our calculations
for the amount of quantum energy there
are there is in the
fluctuations and so I was trying to hack
the energy of the vacuum right and the
reality is that you can't just directly
hack it it doesn't it's not technically
free energy your lack of knowledge of
the fluctuations means you can't extract
the energy but just like you know in the
stock market if you have a stock that's
correlated over time the vacuum is
actually correlated so if you measured
the vacuum at one point you acquired
information if you communicated that
information to another point you can
infer uh what configuration the vacuum
is in to some precision and
statistically extract on average some
energy there so you've quote unquote
teleported energy to me that was
interesting thing because you could
create pockets of negative energy
density which is energy density that is
below the
vacuum which is very weird because H we
don't understand how the vacuum
gravitates um and there are theories
where the vacuum or the canvas of
SpaceTime itself is really a a canvas
made out of quantum entanglement and I
was studying how decreas ing energy of
the vacuum locally increases quantum
entanglement which is very
funky um and so the thing there is that
you know uh if you're
into you know weird theories about you
know uaps and whatnot you know uh you
could try to imagine that they're
they're around and and how would they
Propel themselves right how would they
um go faster than the speed of light you
would need a sort of negative energy
density and to me I gave it the old
College try trying to hack the energy of
the vacuum and hit the limits allowable
by the laws of physics but um there's
all sorts of caveats there where uh you
can't extract more than you've you've
put in obviously but you're saying it's
possible to teleport the energy because
you
can extract information one
place and then make based on that some
kind of prediction M about another place
I'm not sure what I make of that yeah I
mean it's it's uh allowable by the laws
of physics the the reality though is
that the correlations Decay with
distance and so you're going to have to
pay the price not too far away from
where you extract it
sure